there's like a membrane that contains
all the juice inside of it it popped in
my mouth like for future of our
friendship can you not use the word
membrane while I
today we're trying food from Ikea I've
never had any of this food before I
thought IKEA ice cream I heard about the
meatball unfortunately they do have pork
in them so as Nicki Minaj says oink oink
no Pig for me don't quote me on that one
I don't eat pork but they have veggie
options so should we try some of these
things
no that's definitely try some so I don't
eat meat so I'm gonna leave the real
super because just looks like something
you can find in a hospital cafeteria
that's exactly what I was gonna say it
looks very barrel but like you sterile
but cute this come with IKEA
instructions I don't know what sauce to
dip the meat into I'm gonna dip it in
the little gravy here okay
wait is that the sauce but the balls are
for the vegetables I have no idea I'm
gonna okay yeah go ahead go for it okay
sauce free whoa yeah this meats really
soft yeah I think when you try to other
sauce lingonberries balls
it's very Thanksgiving me sweet sauce it
smells like strawberries though yeah oh
no just dip it in gravy it's a bit
stronger than I would expect
they're like tartness to this yeah it's
like I don't know Swedish cranberry
sauce that he's like a melted down
starboard
have you ever seen broccoli that color
no this looks like a weed nug wait look
at that that clustering it's incredible
I can see the fractals in this then I'm
holding the only legal in a few states
so this tastes like every veggie plus
air how's that membrane smell Oh
[Music]
I'm good I'm done
[Music]
we got salmon because we're really fancy
see it's swedish fish get it so with the
lemon sauce over the salmon because we
fancy got some broccoli cauliflower
really into the vegetables I'm excited
about this vegetable loaf okay so shall
we let's get it oh cool
the outside is really soft really fatty
I'm surprised by how good this is has a
very fishy taste yes you know like the
lemon sauce is not do you know no it
doesn't right now with how much you're
enjoying this it's tasting more and more
like filet-o-fish no fried guys let me
take a piece of this what is it you know
mystery I know maybe I'm just barreling
through this everything on this plate
tastes like fish it really just tastes
like vegetables to me there's like
potato and onion and broccoli
it's like potato with green beans inside
I like that yeah no that was that was a
winner except for the parts that were
too close to the fish I like the
meatballs better or the veggie meatballs
yeah he made meatballs it's cake time
this is the Dame cake or I'm gonna put
my money on dying also really love the
cultural garb why does it all the food
come on I think I'll leave that first so
this has pieces of like really famous
candy bars in it it should be really
good oh yeah
I'm all for it is mmm it softer than I
expected but it is so much better than
everything else we've eaten here that's
really sweet it is really sweet it's
really faint it's good it's really rich
it's really sweet this is that could
definitely have too much of this yeah
what's you're made out of I wonder um
future that's a little bit of heaven so
it's like someone melted a crunch bar on
top of the cake the food tastes so good
with some coffee
Wow I was gonna say ice cream Oh ice
cream too with them coffee that'd be
good this is a good comfort food
I'm less sad after eating this
we got IKEA just grab some meatball grab
a cake get your new desk oh this would
look nice on your desk I was hoping this
third course that carrots - what was
your experience like today I'm all linen
IKEA they weren't my first choice to go
grab furniture before now they're my
first choice to go grab a meal
I felt the vegetarian stuff was pretty
good a lot of carrots and broccoli and
cauliflower so a lot of fiber the
dessert is really good that first dish
was pretty much Hispanics giving I would
have this again
[Music]
you